foreign
about the removal of the Conex boxes
removing those containers
allows people to walk straight across we
have some direct and specific challenges
and this adds to
um our already full plate
going back to early
2022
the mayor and I had the opportunity to
sit down with secretary mayorkas
and when he was here in Yuma to do a
border tour he acknowledged our concerns
we had drugs coming across that area and
we had the human trafficking and then we
had large numbers of people camping out
when the numbers grew and border patrol
wasn't able to process
so he made commitments to us to complete
the walls in those areas or to complete
the fence
and you need to remember that all of
that material is sitting on the ground
waiting to be erected it's all
constructed it's all put together the
panels are built and so he said it
shouldn't take long we kept following up
we had an additional conversation about
four months later and he said what
contracts were being administered and
they should be able to get everything
taken care of by August September so we
were biting our time and it didn't
happen
I shared that with Governor Ducey and
also shared with him the concerns that
we had from the agricultural Community
as they were beginning to plant we
absolutely must keep people out of our
agricultural production areas for food
security they are completely exposed
right there and if these if these conics
boxes come down they would be forced to
hire security again
people felt more secure and they were
happy that action was being taken that
they hadn't been forgotten about because
it had been you know months since the
commitments were made to us uh that
these areas were going to be closed up
and nothing happened and so Border
Patrol was actually able to detail
people to that one area where people
were coming across and then redeploy
their manpower to those other areas to
focus on the human and the drug
trafficking Governor Ducey took action
because the feds wouldn't it's
lamentable that the state had to set
aside resources and appropriate State
funds to take care of something that's a
federal responsibility
it was temporary and that's that was why
it was a perfect solution because they
locked together and they can be unlocked
and they can be moved it was temporary
the state should not have had to act
now because of Governor ducey's actions
the administration who said not one more
foot offense or not one more uh wall
will be constructed is now finally
having to act and they're having to
acknowledge to a certain degree the
challenge that we have here along the
border
they have failed to live up to any of
their commitments so far so I'm not
holding my breath this is the commitment
that the secretary made to us
the wall sections are sitting right here
he was able to see them with his own
eyes they've already been bought and
paid for the contractors are still
sitting on site can't anybody do
anything in order to you know give us
that additional security it doesn't even
begin to address you know the illegal
immigration but uh you know keeping
those barriers in place and funneling to
one specific spot and giving the
advantage border patrol is critical
my biggest fear is that the cartels and
individuals around the world see it as
an open invitation to crash our border
and that the human tragic the human
smuggling and the narcotic smuggling
would escalate and destabilize this area
to a point where it is dangerous for the
citizens of Yuma and dangerous for
anybody engaged in any type of activity
along the border